desantis says there's something going on
with desantis and trump right now that's
a little bit uh i don't know if you guys
are following the story closely or not
desantis says he regrets not speaking
out much louder against trump's
recommendation to stay home okay
the saint is this is a cnn story
florida governor desantis said one of
his biggest recruit in office was not
speaking out much louder in march 2020
former when former president trump
advised the nation to stay home to slow
the fast spreading coronavirus the
census blame people like dr anthony
voucher for advising trump to consider
shutdown fauci the country's top
infectious disease expert was part of
the coronaviz response team that led by
vice president mike pence and included
other health public experts uh public
health experts but the decision was
trump's to make and desantis ultimately
followed the white house lead closing
florida schools government buildings
gyms bars and restaurants dining rooms
and advising floridians to stay home
the other day trump was being
interviewed uh who was being interviewed
by was it hannah oh no he was being
interviewed i don't know who was being
interviewed by and he said you know
there are certain governors out there
that don't even have the backbone to say
they've taken a booster didn't say name
didn't say name but we know the girl
that always interviews trump what's her
name from fox business uh bart toronto
is it uh maria bartoroma
she was interviewing desantis and she
said hey governor santas have you taken
a booster and he didn't necessarily say
yes
didn't say yes i've taken a booster
trump when he was asked by hannity he
said yes what do you think is going on
here between trump and desantis
i think i think desantis is trying to
put distance between himself and trump
you know show that there's a difference
between him and how he handles things
because i mean like what trump is still
the front-runner right for the
nomination i mean that he's in the
republican party
he's still yeah he's still a
front-runner um desantis you know has
received a lot of praise from the right
on his handling of things uh criticism
from the left you know they called him
death stantis and all of that um but you
know the lockdowns were so heavily
criticized on the right and a lot of
people saw it early on a lot of people
said hey if we keep kids home there's
gonna be problems if we if we if we stay
inside you know there's gonna be there's
gonna be drug problems there's gonna be
depression there's gonna be suicides
there's going to be that you know people
were really telling a warning about what
would happen and a lot of people went
along with that i think it's good that
he's saying that he regrets not coming
against the strong i don't know that you
know
hindsight's always 20 20 right like can
you really know that that would have
been the right thing to impose at that
time uh maybe not but i think he's
trying to distance himself from i got a
question for you follow up on that on
that topic sure
the only
reason
he would distance himself
is because
he may run in 20 20 23 2024 because
if he really doesn't want to run for
president in 2023 2024
he wouldn't push too hard against trump
because he's gonna need trump's votes in
2028 so if he goes this angle the way i
perceive it is i think there's a my
chances of desantis wanting to run
officially went up 20 30 percent simply
because of his comment he made here
because that's how i see it you have no
other motive to call out trump in this
in this setting here then wait if you
really only run in 2028 i think he's
running i don't know i think he's
running in 2024 no i listen
that what he just said right there he's
trying to tell you
voting for me is very different than
voting for trump yeah that's a campaign
message again i may be wrong i think my
message works in the general election
there listen
if trump wants the republican nominee
everyone should just stay home and not
even waste their freaking time
republicans are on board with trump if
you're a anti-trump rhino whatever dude
move over trump has that nomination now
do i think trump is going to go get
elected in the general election likely
not but we'll see we'll see if if he's
still as polarizing when it comes to
2024 i don't think biden is going to run
again in 2024 if if i'm desantis i look
at the nonsense and i say i know you
might disagree you think he should you
know strike while the iron's hot i look
at the nonsense and i say dude
i'll just see you guys in 2028 and just
be the man and just and and and
completely dominate at that point i
don't think he wants to be in trump's
shadow i think that is
not good for his long-term legacy being
trump's vp i don't think that's his look
gerard you die the hero you live long
enough to see yourself become the
villain he's hot right now he's never
going to be hotter there's never going
to be a weaker opponent if he's ever
going to run it's now if he waits four
years that's four more years but what do
you mean by a weaker opponent
the democratic party is yeah but i'm not
even talking about he has not even like
you got to get through your primary
before you even think about democrats
right now
do you think here's the question for
sure you're a pretty smart guy
if desantis runs
and obviously trump i think is gonna run
is there any chance desantis
you know unseats trump as the um
as the nominee you the republican party
i think you'd be shocked
how many people traditional
conservatives would back desantis over
trump i i think that the map do you
think desantis would beat trump in a
primary is that what you're saying i'm
not saying that whatsoever i'm saying i
think it would be a better fight than
you think it would be and i i i
personally believe mega has always been
less about donald trump and more about
somebody anybody willing to fight back
against the
the the the globalist i think it's just
trump that's it no i couldn't right
can desantis beat trump in a primary
yeah for sure
for sure yeah there's no way you can
have that kind of confidence for sure
can desantis beat trump in a primary let
me ask you a question why would you ask
a question if you weren't going to
accept an answer that came from the i
just i let me ask you a question do you
think white is black no it's not you're
an idiot what kind of a question is that
i just i i i respect the fact that you
actually think that way but i just you
think actually somebody in in today's
climate you think anybody can beat trump
in a republican primary i swear to god i
think sometimes man you wake up in the
middle of the night and you think donald
trump's standing over your bed or
something like that he's not a boogie
man the guy has the guy has 85
90 approval rating in the republican
party if not if it's higher than that
what's desantis
desantis isn't doing well in florida i
don't think people know him on the
national level ask you this how much
overlap do you think
donald trump's audience is with ron
desantis's
how much overlapping similar beliefs
similar values similar how much over
those policies very similar very similar
how much overlap do you think there is
in ron desantis audience to donald
trump's
who has broader appeal
nationally sure desantis i i said i
would vote for desantis i wouldn't vote
for trump so like you said the twelve
percent you just answered yourself who
can yeah but i'm not in the republican
primary do you talk about rape
thought that it was john kasich who made
it to the end of the last
yeah dude no that's i mean well that's a
traditional you know romney-esque
republican
governor of ohio every establishment gop
all the establishment gop money all the
donors they're all going to go what do
you think what do you think about
whether he'll run yeah
whether
he can beat trump if he runs
uh i mean these the polls change all the
time uh it's hard to predict those
things i i as of not if it was held
today i don't think he can beat trump
um
you know we'll see what happens over the
course of time what else happens what
else i think the media has done a very
good job of painting desantis as
reckless and uh getting you know when
you go outside of florida and people
when they hear about what's going on in
florida you know a lot of people think
that florida is like
being like like running to the ground by
the san francisco he's just killing
people you know the media is like is
doing a good job
everybody's moving to florida i think
you're way off man i got so many friends
and family in new york new jersey
connecticut they think ron desantis is
running the promised land down here yeah
well i mean the numbers are people
flooding here there's something part of
that out but there's some startup dude
i'm in nevada i'm in california i'm in
different places here's what everybody
says
dude how bad is florida right now i'm
like what do you mean how bad is floor
it all depends on where they are
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you